hey what's going on what's going on it's
it's bill burr then this is the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast and I just checking it
on yeah just check oh I'm eating my
balls doo doo doo doo doo doo on that
damn stage ba-bump own
oh well freckles is paying the [__]
price he's paying the price every
comedian that has a special coming up
you know in the next couple of weeks
whenever the [__] they're putting it out
I believe the rumor I heard a rumor
Bananarama oh yeah what are they gonna
get back together huh [__] every year
that goes by everybody was talking about
when's Guns and Roses gonna get back
together when Zach cyl and slash gonna
but what about Bananarama I heard a
rumor they were getting back together
for a summer [__] tour I'm paying the
price every goddamn all the comedians
out there Payne who have a special
coming out is that you just go on stage
and you have you know you got nothing
you got in one little [__] you got
one little peashooter and then you got a
slingshot and [__] whatever two
months earlier you had a howitzer of a
[__] act and it's the weirdest
[__] thing just imagine if whatever
if you're an athlete or something like
every couple of years you had to relearn
not all the mechanics but you just
couldn't hit the jump shot anymore
you had to [__] yeah that that shot
was in my repertoire now I got to
relearn how to [__] do this in a
simple in a different way I got to do it
in it I got to shoot it with my left
hand now cuz they already saw me do it
with my right hand and then the more you
[__] do it the more hours you put out
right then you go when I got to bounce
it off my [__] head cuz you know you
can't keep doing the same [__] or
everybody's lega more they say
dude that reminds me of this thing you
do another guy with this person right
you just got to [__] deal with that
so last night you know of course I have
to go on after Ian Edwards I am
Edwards who's one like that guy all he
has is a level [__] material just up
there murdering and I went up there with
my little basic [__] horseshit I was
in a really [__] dark place it's
funny to be in a dark place and then
like you know mentally just like and
then to be talking about the [__] that I
was talking about and I don't know but I
got a plow through this [__] as far as
like I got to get past my anger and I'm
telling you this [__] exercise that I
did the that I'm really starting to
think my shoulders
how [__] do you put your shoulders up
remember that bit I used to do I think I
was stuck in a defensive posture like
shell-shocked yeah I mean there's only
so many times you can get slapped in the
back of the head by bigger kids before
your shoulders are just naturally up
like you're already beginning to block
whatever's coming at you [__] head
and I think I was kind of stuck in that
and you know I was talking to some
people about that it was like well you
know there's physical ailments and then
there's the emotional [__] trauma of
what's going on with your life and
there's certain people that think
they're related I don't know if you guys
aren't into that but you look up this
stuff you know this is like one of these
things when you go to look this up you
completely leave the medical profession
in the United States of America like you
start like the doctors slowly start
wearing less and less shoes as you start
to go further east with your you're
looking for medical solutions you know
if you're looking for a medical solution
in the United States of of the Americas
it's gonna be a guy in wing tip shoes
with [__] dark socks you know fully
clothed being like okay yeah you got a
your rotator cuff is dipped up though we
need to go in and operate and take the
medial cart over that well well the
[__] MCL and all they're gonna give
you this straight [__] how the body
works we've done an MRI this is what the
[__] is going on with your body but then
as you start to go you know you start to
step away from that [__] the
pharmaceutical companies and all that
not saying it's all bad not saying it's
all bad ones last time we had
like you know for as much as the
pharmaceutical companies allegedly
allegedly created a heroin epidemic in
this country by handing out opiates like
Flintstone vitamins to [__] adults
you know there's L say no because
nobody's walking around with scurvy so
that's something right I guess no one
really walked around with scurvy Billy
had to be on a [__] boat lost at sea
you know no wind in your sails an Iron
Maiden singing right
so yeah but the further you go down that
rabbit hole like the [__] the longer
the hair gets then there's like you know
more loose-fitting clothes then it
becomes sandals and then just sort of
the more you know me any very striking
like this and then I get all [__]
uncomfortable I'll look up somebody hit
pause her and I'm gonna look up some
[__] about like the memories I mean let
me see what this [__] doctor looks
like perfect perfect [__] perfect so
I looked up memories held in and
immediately came up was in body
so of course Wikipedia has something
that's just gonna be like you know the
old right there Fred so the first thing
I scrolled down to that was not
Wikipedia was tiny Buddha all right and
I swear to God it says how to release
the painful memories and emotions stored
in your body by Jennifer Stirling of
course now they're gonna let a woman do
something right they're not going to let
her in the wingtip world so the picture
you see is some Antonio Banderas looking
guy with the I call it the gay cut
t-shirt you know you know that you know
the v-neck t-shirt that the [__] gay
guys wear cuz they're all [__] in
crazy shape your enemy it's not the dad
bod cut it's the gay male [__] cut
where they have chest cleavage because
they have 0% body fat so the guys
dressed white on white with the gay cut
tee and yoga pants no [__] shoes and
he's on the beach not a hospital he
looks like [__] a good-looking Tom
Hanks in castaway if he didn't give a
[__] that he was castaway castaway yeah
and he didn't need to talk to a soccer
ball cuz he was so [__] centered
and he breathed his way through how the
[__] did he become a castaway I can't
even remember they must have been his
ship sank right I was he flying with
Amelia I don't know was it one of those
Tarantino movies where he kind of [__]
with history
alright the cure for pain is in the pain
says somebody named Rumi and then says
free download Buddha desktop wallpaper
that kind of kills it you know when you
have look at Jesus or a Buddha or a
Mohammed like wallpaper you know what I
mean kind of cheeses it up a little bit
now you think okay it's all right let me
read in my best yoga voice your body
keeps a physical memory of all your
experiences you have lots of memories
stored in your brain that you can count
at any given moment you can call names
faces yeah I get out my [__] brain
works what you [__] sandwich smelled
like but over time these memories fade
or changed as time passes as and we
mature however even when the memory
begins to favor you rank get to the
[__] point it lives in your body in
the form of a physical sensation and
behavior patterns the body doesn't
forget now Jesus what's your body from
Hell's Kitchen your brains all forgiving
like hey man like you know not gonna lie
I didn't enjoy it when it happened but
you know God I mean just a sunny day
just go out and enjoy it alright the
events of our lives leave physical
imprints in our bodies especially when
we experience trauma okay okay stress
and all this [__] that caused the body
to fight flee or freeze in order to cope
this is what I'm saying I think I was
all [__] now I was in a you know
after you take a couple of [__] right
left to the head you just kind of you
just walk around I just saw that I you
know I have like [__] 40 years ago
whatever the [__] I was in high school
40 years ago was I 18 no that was 30
years ago 30 years ago I was [__] 18
yeah I'm uh
you knew that phone was gonna ring
who is this who the hell is this I
should have put it on pause who is this
hello hello for [__] sake can you
believe someone would pocket-dial me
during my podcast you know it's funny I
have no idea what the [__] that was they
have no idea who the [__] I am
that's what's always fascinated me about
when you just [__] you just dial a
wrong number I've said this before right
you dial a number and somebody says
hello and you're like yeah hey his is
Frank there and they're like who and
you're like and they're like oh I'm
sorry they're like I'm sorry you have
the wrong number
now I get wrong numbers everybody gets
wrong numbers there's my question to you
do you think you've ever accidentally
called somebody famous you know what I
mean like you just [__] I don't know
you just dial the wrong number and like
Bill Clinton picked up a [__] Obama
Oh throw a Republican in there George
Bush he's daddy right he [__] picks
up and you can he has to go through the
same [__] is you're like his Frank there
and it's a high introduced yeah there's
no quitting there's no Frank here yeah
you should I love them they breed the
[__] number T like you don't know
what your number is it's this blob no it
is it that's why there's no Frank here
anyways let me continue one all right
well [__] all this [__] how do I get it
out of me
cuz my body it never forgets it's like
[__] me and Lisa if you punch me in
the [__] head that was great um wait
a minute I love that they finally gave
Jamie Foxx the [__] Liam Neeson role
he has a movie coming out where it's one
of those movies like you [__] with my
family I'm gonna [__] kill you it's
about time you know they ran out of
young white guys to give that to and
then they just kept going over like Liam
Neeson is I mean that guy's like what
he's only 83 then he play like [__]
obi-wan Kenobi or some [__] all right
the first tool to put your emotional
toolkit ah
the first tool to put in your emotional
toolkit and this is why this is why I've
never been able to get through this [__]
because I was gonna know because I'm
[__] up but when I start to go down
this road of doctors who don't wear
shoes like it's okay the pictures that
they have okay it says how to set new
year's goals you'll actually enjoy
pursuing and it's a stick figure sitting
on a rainbow staring up at the Sun with
a big goofy smile on its face and I
don't know about you guys but where I
came from that sort of happiness was not
allowed you basically were not allowed
to be happy and it was shamed [__] off
oh no wait why am i letting that react
why am i reacting to that I have the
power I could have you know what's funny
right before I started this I was
thinking I should go into the settings
and I should just turn it off and I
didn't so I created this situation not a
dead Steve Jobs huh
you know I I guess I could get upset
with Steve Jobs with how [__] many
times that thing rings before it goes to
voicemail but then I imagine that I
could actually go into settings and I
could determine that I just don't have
the patience all right the first tool
okay guys your first tool to put in your
emotional toolkit this is the type of
class I would go to with Nia and she
would just feel me either starting to
get mad or just laughing at the thing as
she being the [__] angel that she is
an open [__] channel would be like
okay gate what is the first emotional
tool it's cuz she's a woman she gets to
[__] do that be like oh my god let's
get some s'mores they get to be like
that we're not you know you don't have a
[__] bottle opener you got to use
your teeth you know it's just such
stupid guys [__]
and if you don't know how to [__] do
that thing when you bring your beer up
to the counter and [__] slam it down
you know you're somehow less of a man I
like how I'm putting on all my issues
onto you guys all right let's see if we
go okay the first tool to put in your
emotional toolbox non-judgement [__] I
mean there goes my stand-up career I
mean my entire [__] life is judging
people all right when you feel
emotionally triggered and tempted to
turn to food or other addictive
behaviors for comfort I'm not a well
maybe I am a drunk try not to judge the
reaction our bodies are programmed to
seek pleasure not discomfort so it's
natural to try and find something to
soothe the pain and make yourself feel
better
the need to suit yourself with food I'm
not a fat [__] or other means doesn't
make you a bad person it makes you human
oh this is just so gross the second tool
permission the third tool release I
can't read this the fourth tool
forgiveness finally time oh my god I'm
in the wrong website Jennifer sterling
is an emotional eating coach well what
the [__] is this at the wrong website
she helps women stop eating their
feelings and released a physical and
mental emotional weight that keeps them
from feeling the absolute best download
the cravings decoder guide and uncovered
the hidden emotional meaning behind your
food cravings I don't want to be a
[__] negative person but doesn't that
sound a little [__] generic I was
craving a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich okay what that means is this
all right where do you store your
emotions where you store your emotions
all right now this person has a PhD so
imagine they're gonna be wearing more
clothes they don't even have a picture
it may surprise you that emotions are
not the sole product of your brain but
our experience Raisa this isn't going to
say the same [__] as the last website
and these emotions can be triggered
through your body work meditation
breathing Baba Baba use one huh
all right you know evidently I'm never
gonna get cured because I can't get to
this [__]
well certainly not while doing a [__]
podcast you [__] why did you just call
yourself a [__] there is that is that
really what you thought or is that what
people told you when you were younger
that's the type of [__] what you just
want to grab the person by their ankles
and drag them out of their chair and
they just walk out of the room Jesus
Christ I'm up against it dude is this
what it's like to become a parent you
just suddenly become hyper aware of how
unqualified you are and what a [__]
[__] you are like someone's gonna be
looking at me like I have questions hey
I mean we talked to my kid like I joined
the club you think any of this [__]
makes sense to me at least you're a kid
you can have the comfort of it's okay
that you don't know [__] where do you
get to be my age and you don't have an
excuse you know and there's that [__]
whatever the [__] is and the Michael Ray
Richardson Tyson Sicily to whatever the
[__] name is quite leave Tyson I
forget what his name is he got like
[__] the the the guy who looks like
the cop on the black cop on Barney
Miller who [__] knows about black
holes in the universe and is a fine wine
connoisseur you know that's the kind of
person you need is a dad that guy that
guy's got [__] answers you know I was
reading a thing on him I could never
remember this guy's [__] name his
last name is Tyson deGrasse Tyson Tyson
scientist Tyson science we'll go with
that doesn't mean Mike Tyson's foot
worth Neil deGrasse Tyson this is why
he's the [__]
because not only is he unbelievably
intelligent he knows that we came from
trees or some [__] whatever the [__] he
was saying you know thank God I don't do
heavy drugs when I watch that guy's show
all right he also was talking about how
he's into wine and he was talking about
how when you did whatever you finish a
bottle of wine you fill it up with water
or you go to you know and you're pouring
it out it does that glub-glub-glub thing
he was just going what you do is you
just turn the bottle is you turn the
bottle it causes a swirling effect and
uh basically because it's swirling down
then there's that hole in the middle
lets the air go in so as as the liquids
coming out and the air can freely flow
in
to take up the space that the liquid
once had and it just flows right out
plus it looks it looks [__] cool as
you do it so the next time you pour a
big [__] glass of wine for some real
housewife you know get you can't wait to
hold her Botox face in your hands you
know you don't want to [__] it up by
glub-glub-glub burn it into a giant
glass cause it might go all over a
[__] dress that she's gonna wear once
you know they look you know that that's
what I get out of Neil deGrasse Tyson i
watch that show and I'm like goddamn it
you know as much as this guy just told
me where we came from
in the universe millions of years ago or
whatever thousands I don't know I'm
gonna go back to Jesus that was only
what couple thousand years ago as much
as he's teaching me about that he's also
on the side showing me how to bang a
real housewife anyways
so I've continued to get rid of [__] and
I'm still in my office that's how much
[__] I had I had two closets and
everything in my room and I [__] I've
gotten rid of everything and I might
even do another pass cuz I have to tell
you I [__] walk in there now
and I'm relaxed I had no idea that when
you walk in and there's a ton of [__]
the level of stress that was bringing me
up [__] relaxed and like there's my
drunk kid there's my guitar there's
where I keep my pens you know get it out
of here anything that's coming in the
house get it the [__] out and so then
yesterday of course you know you know
women are you know you know you know
they are I mean if if they're not
[__] you know watching a real
housewife show if they're not eating
something they're they're on Amazon
buying something they just they they
they [__] consume [__] so you know
it's been the holidays so we've had a
bunch of boxes people sending us stuff
we're selling them [__] in there by my
front door every date is these [__]
boxes okay so what I always do is I take
our [__] address off it I put it
through the paper right then I cut the
boxes up and then I take them over this
[__] place that uh you know one of
those mailboxes separate places you know
and I say you go is some free [__]
boxes they take it now I don't know if
they throw it out like good
but I feel like I made the [__]
effort you know but I can't [__] keep
the goddamn door clean and I cut up like
[__] 20 of these goddamn boxes you
know did you wait to you have a [__]
baby everybody sends your [__]
everybody's sending your [__] socks
shoes swings all of this [__] and it's
just like yeah I just love the amount of
socks that they send you it's like it's
not gonna be able to walk for like the
first [__] I don't know six months
what does it need socks for what do you
get me a hang glider I mean just is that
doesn't even make any [__] sense I
know you the baby's got to keep its feet
warm but does it have to have one pair
of socks for every [__] day of its
six-month life you know and then what
you got all these little socks it's
gonna grow out of them and like [__]
tense out you see what level of a [__]
would you have to be to look at the
cutest thing ever little baby sucks and
it still makes you upset so you don't
say I'll tell you freckles needs to help
here
alright let's get to some of the let's
get to some of the announcements oh by
the way everybody I keep forgetting to
promote this the Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit v Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit
I still have a nice photo on the wall
somebody that is great painting of him
the perfect size and all that that I
will never get rid of now having said
that I don't need any more all right
Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit this is
the fifth annual one at the New York
City Center all right we're gonna post
the link and all of that there's uh it's
a 2,000 seater we got a couple hundred
seats left and it's a great way to start
your year and it's one of my favorite
shows of the year just getting to see
all of the just all my friends and outs
becoming like newer guys that were
influenced by Patrice and they come when
they talk about you know the amazing
comic that he was and I got to tell you
that will never not be in the back of my
head because I love the guide to death
but it's also like whenever someone will
come up to me and give me a high
compliment you
now as far as where I am in the comedy
world right now as a stand-up comedian I
always think that's because Patrice
isn't here right now in Mitch Hedberg
and Geraldo and all these other monsters
that we lost so this is an incredible
benefit and it you know through the
money that we've raised his mother's
been able to get a condominium and she's
living great she doesn't have to worry
about anything you know you know the
only thing you know and that's my really
a belief of mine that when somebody
passes and their family members are you
know the only thing they should have to
deal with is the grief of it which
unfortunately you never totally get past
but they shouldn't also have to deal
with all this other stuff which is why
we continue to do the benefit because I
always hated when I was coming up when
there was an unexpected death and the
person had a family and all of that type
of [__] you know it's like you do one
benefit and it's like okay here's your
bag of loot you know try to make this
last for the next 20 30 40 50 [__]
years I don't know so that's why we
continue to do it plus it keeps the the
memory of him alive and all of his
comedy out there that is the hope anyway
so okay so now on to the advertising the
black tux dot-com all right looking
great for a wedding or special event has
never been easier
with black tux calm with high quality
rental suits and tuxedos delivered to
your doorstep the black tux is giving
guys a new way to rent and get this the
black tux offers free home try on try
ons so you can see the fit and feel the
quality of your suit months before your
event through these [__] companies
man this is like you're not gonna have
to leave your house anymore you can get
food sent to your house wine sent to
your house and a [__] tuxedo you know
and God knows [__] have always been it
willing to come to you [__] this is so
this is the final this is a final piece
of the puzzle like you're putting
together a championship team all you
were missing was the [__] tuxedo
you go to blue apron to get your [__]
food right
you go to [__] lootcrate to get your
t-shirt that you're gonna wear
underneath all the [__] you go to
[__] something at me undies right to
get your sexy Greg Louganis on right and
then you got the [__] Roger Moore
Roger Moore right Sean Connery tux how
do you how do you do this it's the best
part it's just done completely online no
trips to the tux tuxedo shop required
the black tux doll that's the worst when
you go to the tuxedo shop there's always
that guy who's been there for like
forever and he's got that [__] tape
measure around his [__] neck whatever
the [__] you call that thing you know
the you know those people don't clean
their ears to the point that everything
just turns black in there
looks like somebody lit a firecracker
off in both their [__] ears sorry the
black tux calmly lets you create your
look or choose from tons of styles
selected outfits starting at just $95
these suits have a modern fit and are
made from the Italian fine Italian wool
the highest quality on the rental market
you're gonna buy a [__] wool suit
okay and if you have any questions or
issues they're expert yeah why is this
itch e there's gotta be some new kind of
woeful like mad at a modal or something
now if you have any questions or issues
their expert customer care has your back
every step of the way after ordering you
your suit will arrive 14 days before
your event
why don't I pay attention to commas
after ordering comma your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event that's
a full two weeks to try it on and make
sure everything fits if anything is less
than perfect the black tux will send you
a free replacement right away when your
events over just drop your rental back
in the mail shipping is free both ways
how easy is that to get started now
visit the black tux calm slash / b you
are r and experience a new way to rent
the black tux dot-com / / alright
feasto c so [__] you man
alright see so is the place for comedy
they won't tell you how amazing they are
but I will see so is amazing
so I just feel like you know one of my
fault anybody says see so this is I
don't they don't take responsibility for
their actions but see so anybody does
that is it's going to see some amazing
content see that it's comedy for nerds
by comedy nerds see so spelled SE eso
Sierra echo echo Sierra Oscar is the new
ad free streaming service bringing you a
hilarious original series hand-picked
classics weeks of stand-up specials and
more bin jabal comedy anytime anywhere
see so every episode of SNL including
new episodes the day after they air The
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon Late
Night with Seth [__] - the day after
it airs and even they even have classics
like 30 Rock's dirty [__] sorry Parks
and Recreation and Saved by the Bell
30 rocks is a documentary on crack
cocaine sorry even British comedies like
the original office with Ricky Gervais
the entire Monty Python catalog the it
crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge
discovered the big names in comedy and
watch the icons before they made it big
like louis c.k what he had hair ah there
was no reason to do that you know laughs
[__] you like the original you when you
had a life chelsea peretti Amy [__]
Schumer bo burnham and so many more
critically acclaimed originals and
exclusive content like Harmon quest
created by comedian Dan Harmon and funny
as hell a variety show featuring such
comedians as Jim Jeffries and Hannibal
Buress if you're serious about comedy
you got a try see so streaming anytime
anywhere on any virtual device is it me
or is this ad way too [__] long see
so is ad free just 399 per month that's
less than what you paid for a latte or
an artisan cold brew coffee you hold it
right now you bearded [__] and right now
my listeners can try see so for free for
two months when you use the promo code
burr to check it out shows you can't get
anywhere else from critically acclaimed
original
series to all 40 plus years of SNL
that's why I'm getting it right there
see so is the only original play the
only place that offers every episode
every made and new episodes the day
after the air just go to sea so calm
right now to sign up for two months for
free with the promo code Burr and check
out that sea SOCOM promo code birth
check it out you can do it for [__]
free oh look who's here
our furrow friend's boat Oh put me on DS
biondi's doctors who don't wear shoes
boo doot doot doot me on DS Biondi ricky
gervais strengths bro when he [__]
hosts the Golden Globes Auto his balls
filled nobody knows but if he had on me
undies his voice would even be higher
when he made [__] milk fun a [__]
Mel Gibson oh yeah alright huh my undies
picture a world we're putting on a new
pair of underwear isn't just fresh
that's [__] gross you know I mean as
opposed to what Dale balls hanging in
the things you're stepping into a better
day think about it underwear it's the
first thing you put on lasting you take
off unless you're Matthew McConaughey
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet please include all of the
following point I always include them if
you write it I will read it if you build
it they will come the undies focuses
solely on producing the most comfortable
underwear you've ever experienced it's
just what is going on with other
people's underwear it's it's attacking
my ass crack over here my undies for my
friends at me undies we're not friends I
never met these [__] people sent me a
few pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine wearing anything else of course
I can okay I'm a very fluid person all
right now if I don't have me undies
I'll wear by my hand Z's oh my fruit of
the Loom Z's it's really easy it's
really makes each day that much better
for the price of two cocktails me undies
will dwell you know thing two cocktails
home pours we talking around at a
[__] bar B undies will deliver your
new pair of favorite underwear right to
your doorstep better day guarantee you
try them on if they're not the most
comfortable best feeling [__] on the
way you've ever had their refunds you
and let you keep your first pair for
free included in the price is the sweet
touch of
a special fabric made with the
best-in-class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton scientifically proven
by what the scientists that you hired
that are on your payroll maybe it's only
two and a half times who knows I'll let
my balls be the judge of that your uber
cozy underwear undies are sold
exclusively on me undies website well
you'll enjoy free shipping in the US and
Canada for a limited time everyone in my
audience gets 20% off their nut cradle
errs always so make up for women too but
you have to go to our special URL me
undies com / / with the me undies better
day guarantee you have nothing to lose
so don't wait any longer go to me undies
calm / burger right now 20% off your
order
that's me honey calm / / no longer will
your balls fall out the side of your
underwear with this snug fit and if they
do the undies will I don't know what
they'll do but all I know is it's gonna
be the sweetest softest ball roll to the
left or the right depending on where
your junk is that you ever felt in your
life
before it starts its freefall down to
your [__] kneecap alright that was
disgusting bill it was disgusting it
wasn't socially redeemable and I don't
think anybody became a better person
listening to it alright so is that the
podcast that is the podcast now when I
get off the podcast I'm gonna go look at
these barefoot doctors you know I can't
[__] believe a that you know the
misrepresentative that [__] site you
know they have some guys sitting there
right with the gay cut t-shirt and I'm
sitting there thinking like alright this
is gonna be for angry fuckos like me
it's for a bunch of women who every time
their boyfriend says hey you know I
don't feel like getting going to see
that movie tonight and rather stay yeah
and they go oh they go and they eat a
[__] death by chocolate [__] thing
I don't know I don't know what I'm
complaining about anymore I really don't
I'm just freaking out because I got a
kid coming I would just like the kid to
show up already so I can get on with
that part of my life is to put this but
this is literally what it's like
sometimes this reminds me obviously to a
much emotionally heightened state
but I always remember when I would be
standing the side of the stage and it
was just a [__] brutal crowd and I
knew that they were gonna scream and
yell the entire [__] show and it was
just gonna be 45 minutes of pure [__]
hell
I always remember just the worst part
was not going out there it was waiting
the second I got out there I didn't give
a [__] because it's just like every
second I'm out here is one less as I am
a second closer to this [__] being
over it's like doing cardio getting on
the [__] thing and doing it it's not
a [__] problem it's it's the
stretching beforehand you know putting
on the workout clothes dragging your ass
over the machine the second you get on
the thing I'm a little thirty seconds
into it you're listening to your tones
you having a good [__] time
everything is [__] great it's it's
the getting it's the get in there at
least for me and you know what I think
that that's you know something that we
can all relate to is it I don't [__]
know anyways uh I start to watch the
Celtics last night against Utah I got to
watch that one because I think the
Bruins are playing today and I'm trying
to do this I'm gonna watch every Bruins
in every Celtic game that I possibly can
it's fun I got to tell you something I
never realized because I haven't watched
it so long when you watch NBA hoop it's
so easy to start to get to know your
team because they got a starting five
you know what I mean
Patriots you got 11 guys on offense 11
guys on defense basketball has five five
starters that play they start both ways
offense and defense running down the
[__] court now you on defense you
know I guess the Bruins just have a
starting line and then they're starting
to defenseman that's five and they got a
goalie but thing about well you know I
don't know I mean [__] players are in
a hockey team how [__] up is that all
these years our watch and I don't like
football there's like 41 42 people you
know of which if you know like ten of
them you kind of know your [__] team
what do you guys think I'm gonna say
there's like 25 guys well let's see
there's four [__] lines four lines
three guys on a line that's 12 you got
two goaltenders
that's 14 and then you got like what
eight defenseman something like that six
to eight yeah I'm gonna say about 25
then you got like the guys who don't get
in the game you know with the lose
hockey stuff doesn't smell at all at
least they're there practice stuff
probably smells I'm sure how many
players on a hockey team I'm gonna say
25 under the NHL rules each team is
allowed to have up to 18 players with
additional two goalkeepers for a total
of 20 that's it well there's really no
excuse for me not knowing that's only 20
players right that's when you're on a
crazy level of a sports fan is if you
can name all [__] 20 players on your
hockey team and all what 11 guys on the
basketball team just for the simple fact
that they [__] overlap I would say
and by the way my wife taped these
sports Jeopardy's that were hosted by
Dan Patrick but judging by some of the
questions it was a little dated but uh I
was like finally at Jeopardy I'm gonna
do well on and I still got my [__]
ass kicked because it was [__] hard
[__] like who was the Oh like they had
like bankrupt teams teams that went
bankrupt yet and no the owner's name if
you know the owner's name it's like
you're watching [__] sports talk
radio and all of that shaking me and
[__] bring what's wrong with you you
know our specialty [__] coach you get
to that level you know what I'm just
babbling here I don't have [__] time
to do this all I was doing was checking
in on Ian that that's that's the podcast
have a great weekend yet [__] and no no
no no why am i why you know what why do
I say that
you know why I [__] say that because
I'm defensive if I actually said
something nice to you right then my
shoulders start coming up I hope you
guys have a wonderful rest of your week
I can't do this I can't [__] do this
have a great weekend you [__] [__]
alright I say that in the most loving
way possible alright did that make you
uncomfortable good welcome to my [__]
world and here let's do a little bit of
music and
afterwards we'll play some sub clips
from a podcast card by Thursday that
wanna [__] out maybe on one day who
knows all right go [__] yourselves we'll
talk to you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast the
first one for 2009 so I want to take
some time to wake everybody a oh yeah
sorry I tried I tried it I tried to come
out nice I tried to start it by being I
can't do it I just can't say something
nice why can't I just start my podcast
to be like hey Happy New Year everybody
I hope you had a nice Christmas you know
even though I feel that I can't get
myself to say it I have to mock it I
have to say Happy New Year in a silly
voice you know I can't just feel like
hey happy happy new it Happy New Year
you know that doesn't sound happy or sad
or angry it just sounds like I'm reading
it off the cue card we try to give it
the feeling it deserves hey let me try
again oh I get a phone call hang on one
second hang on hang on one second hello
hey Dan what's going on man
uh I'm actually I'm finishing up a
podcast can I can I call you right back
and like a beautiful I do but yeah okay
that's the [__] tax man so goddamn
tax man every [__] year I think hey I
actually got ahead a little bit and then
what do they do to come out and they
just [__] well I I make the perfect
amount of [__] money in this country
you know nummy I'm not rich enough to
[__] afford somebody to tell the IRS
to go [__] themselves and I'm not broke
so I'm the [__] you know what I am
when you watch the Discovery Channel you
know that that [__] gazelle that's
walking with a limp that's what I am the
[__] lines their ears perk up and
they try to separate me from the [__]
herd that's who I am when the taxman
comes around some goddamn [__]
[__] alright sorry
you know potholes all up and down my
[__] Street you know to me why do I
pay you when I just go down a [__] at
Home Depot and buy some goddamn Tarnoff
all can you buy car and one
poke I'm sure you can but God knows
there's nobody there to help you find it
huh 50,000 [__] square foot store with
200 foot ceilings and they got like
three people with aprons walkin around
you ask them any question they don't
know where the [__] I having a plumbing
section I [__] it shut up go hang
yourself with your rape but not only
you're not you're not the problem
you're not the problem you're the poor
worker sorry about that you know they
actually they got those automated they
got those automated cashiers out here at
the grocery store and you know I get out
and there's a whole bunch of people just
lining up lining up to help the
corporation's fire other Americans I
swear to God if you're one of my podcast
members and you go to the grocery store
and you can you stand in that automated
line I want you to delete yourself as
one of my friends okay I have a zero
[__] tolerance for that [__] it's
it's unbelievable how stupid people are
and I love how they have like the one
employee where his job is literally to
stand there and teach you how to
basically do his job so that they could
then fire you and I know what the
corporation is gonna do that it's going
to help cut costs of food really you got
eight people they're making $8 an hour
that's 64 bucks an hour you got a
thousand people in here buying
cornflakes what do I save half a cent on
my Fruity Pebbles you [__] [__]
there was the first kind of 2009 right
there people stand in line help keep a
fellow American at work huh ba ba ba ba
ba ba dude I'm not even joking don't do
that don't do that [__] these [__]
parking structures with their pay
stations now I have to be the parking
attendant I don't work here I got to be
for free I got to do this for [__]
free and put another guy out of work who
now is walking around trying to fight to
find a job for all I know he's gonna
start writing jokes you know don't do
that [__] don't don't
okay you know me actually you don't know
me you think you know me can you listen
to me every Monday but I'm taking some
myself I don't give a [__] what you do
this is the one time where I'm going to
get up on my goddamn soapbox okay
which is really difficult for me because
I got a big head and my equilibrium
starts to [__] with me when I stand up
on soap boxes which is why I don't
preach but I'm going to preach on this
one do not do that go to the grocery
store
stand in line okay let that mother of
three keep her job okay or that dead
[__] convicted drug driver who's
trying to put his life back together
again
and let them keep their jobs do not
stand and learn how to do it you're
going to do their job for [__] free
and it's not quicker and in the future
you're going to actually have to [__]
stand there and you know what happens
when you need a price check on a [__]
cantaloupe you have to go do it I don't
I just [__] blows my mind we're
already pumping our gas our own gas
people when's it gonna stop
huh okay hell of a week all right
actually you know what I want to know
how you guys feel about that stuff but
my a my you know do you feel like I have
a really good point there because I feel
I do
oh my you know if I was living in the
1800s would I be the guy going stop
churning butter no keep churning butter
don't let them do this for no but that's
not even a fair example because it's not
like there was a maybe there was a bunch
of butter churners if they could somehow
come up with automated buttered butter
churning you know what I really paid my
pay to myself into a corner with that
Deb reference I really had nothing there
all right but I still think I made a
good point there all right let's talk
about my week I had a [__] insane
week and I went to the Rose Bowl with
fellow comedian and I'm not going to
name his name usually I'll do that maybe
give somebody you know bump up their
friends or that type of stuff which I'd
love to do for this guy but our behavior
was so uh colorful that's the word I'll
use that you know just in case you know
what I mean I'm old school I don't name
names when I start talking about semi
crimes that I committed not really
committing I guess being drunk
look is a crime bill why don't you shut
the [__] up and get to the story and
we'll all be the judge fine fine look at
you guys with all the tension beginning
of 2009 you know you guys be more
relaxed this year you know things gonna
be 5 2009 baby although they got a rhyme
you know just make it rhyme and then
didn't then - then I'm supposed to feel
good you know
and I'm not supposed to notice that last
year was things are going to be great in
2008 and now if you've knocked it down
outs things it would be fine things
would be great yeah they can be fine you
know don't freak out in 2010 who did a
combining for Canada in 2011 why am i
[__] checking myself out at a grocery
store and I'm not getting paid for it
okay sorry miss to go to the Rose Bowl
with a comedian we're just going to call
them Joe all right because that's the
classic alias name when you don't want
to get somebody in trouble you just call
them Joe but the ironic thing is this
guy's name is actually Joe so me and Joe
we go to the fellow comedian and you can
try to figure out who the [__] he is
and it's not Piscopo we go to the Rose
Bowl and we had great intentions okay
let me paint a picture for you okay when
you go to the Rose Bowl it's one of the
great tailgating experiences you'll ever
have first of all you go into the Rose
Bowl okay the granddaddy of them all
home of a bunch of Super Bowl the Super
Bowls would falooda that that Super Bowl
if you see that famous Lynn Swann catch
that wasn't made there I actually
realized that was made at Temple
University wasn't it
I don't [__] know there's been a bond
I know the Jackie Slater one we dropped
the ball that's right that that cowboy
Steelers won the greatest [__] I
don't know clash of two powerhouse teams
I ever saw was the honor whatever they
played a bunch of [__] things there
and I don't have the information in
front of me and I'm really killing the
momentum of the story
so anyway see go there right and you get
right behind the Rose Bowl is what I'm
assuming is an 18-hole golf course
because God knows that's how big it felt
at the end of the game when I was too
shit-faced and we couldn't find the car
and we walked before but that's that I'm
getting ahead of myself you know what
I'm foreshadowing I'm doing what all
great movies do you know what I mean you
go see a movie whenever they show movie
about a guy who dies everybody knows
he's going to die so they show him died
in the beginning and then the next scene
is they go back to his childhood you
know what I mean except they never do
that with the Elvis movie because then
they'd have to start the movie with some
fat [__] dying on a toilet and no one
wants to do that yeah is that my
pancreas pop um anyways so Jesus Christ
let's get some momentum here so we
[__] we go to this tailgate alright
and this is the deal basically there's
just two of us and amongst us we have
four hamburger patties two bags of chips
hamburger buns 12-pack of Bud Light
12-pack of Budweiser and a Clint
Eastwood canteen size of [__] Crown
Royal and two Cuban cigars that I snuck
back from [__] Canada so we're ready
to go I got my sunblock we load it up
into the Prius which is which is just
[__] hilarious you know everybody
everybody tries to help man people at
the tailgates people coming up there
with they have their [__] you know
four-door pickups with the lift kits
you know the generators it's got a
[__] satellite dish and a flat-screen
TV you know I came there with a little
hibachi or whatever we had the big thing
at Crown Royal so people and Cuban
cigars so no one [__] with us right so
we're having a great time all of a
sudden this lady comes walking by and
she's like hey do you want to buy a
little ticket holder for your ticket I'm
like absolutely sweetheart
ten bucks a whack let me get let me get
that two times that baby you know you
get a cigar in your mouth you start
getting a little swagger some reason
when he like starts rocking back and
forth like you're going to sing it not
like you got to sing an Elvis song I was
feeling it and the great thing was I
didn't give a [__] about
the team USC or Penn State I was just
happy to [__] be there you know but I
quickly realized most people were for
the Trojans so automatically I'm a [__]
second come to the year I'm like you
know what I'm gonna root for the primal
roots of Penn State because this gives
me way more chance to annoy people plus
I I've never liked USC and most of us do
back in the day I used to be a Notre
Dame fan before Lou Holtz what there
holier holier than thou we don't do
steroids shut the [__] up yes you do all
right I had acne when I was [__] a
teenager right but it wasn't all over my
back and I also couldn't pick up a house
okay so you [__] people are doing
steroids anyways and also I always hated
the Trojans fight song they played every
three seconds bad bad and you know they
gained like half a yard it also reminds
me of Fleetwood Mac who I never liked so
[__] the Trojans right so anyway swish
sit now we're drinking were partying
with eating burgers and then we break
out the Crown Royal after we had
polished off a good half a case between
the two of us it's probably 9:30 in the
morning and we just start pounding this
Crown Royal which is going down like
[__] kool-aid I was really impressed
with my ability or at least Eve the
makers of Crown Royal that is some
smooth [__] so so basically we start
walking towards the stadium and the
alcohol flowing through me and that's
when I go into the my transformation I
don't know what happens to me at
sporting events but instantly I just
become the loud guy I feel like I'm
doing a comedy show I want to make the
people around me laugh and I also want
to irritate as many [__] people as I
can so I start walking in there and I
quickly notice oh I know I went to go
buy a program I'm trying to put this all
back together because I was pretty drunk
I go just to give you an idea of the
mood that I was in I get to about a
hundred yards from the stadium this
lady's selling programs and she's like
yeah I get your problems here come on
get your programs and like I [__] it I
want I want a souvenir so I walk up Mike
how much are they she's like 10 bucks my
guy fine so this other guy comes walk
because how much for the programs and
the ladies like ten bucks
right and the guy starts bitching to be
kidding me right so I'm standing there I
got a Cuban cigar I go you know what let
me get another one
two times let me get two of those all
right one for you over there and the
guys like really I go hey I go take a
look at me they go you know you're
looking at you're looking at a big shot
take a good look there's not a there's
not a lot of us left I swear to god I
said that and I was so drunk I was only
half joking like I knew I was being an
[__] but like I was only half Jew I
have [__] Cuban cigar go [__]
yourself
I'm a big shot let's get a program for
this [__] over here who's [__] in about
ten who goes to Roseville and [__]
about a ten dollar [__] program you
know what I mean he should have been
depantsed and he should have his tickets
removed right there and sent right back
to wherever the [__] Kiki came from
sent to an Applebee's watch the game
there all right kind of [__] behavior
is that is a granddaddy of them all take
your [__] money out and play the
goddamn game all right so anyway so I'm
hammock right and we're [__] we're
walking and I don't know what happen we
we got into the stadium everything was
cool then they have this weird sort of
like they funnel you in because it's a
really old Stadium it's like you know
it's like trying to go through the
Lincoln Tunnel like five o'clock at
night it's a pain in the ass
so I'm standing there I'm getting
frustrated because it's getting close to
kickoff and I hate missing kickoff so
I'm getting pissed and I noticed that
the Penn State fans they got this chant
where one of them I don't know where
just yells we are and then all the Penn
State fans go Penn State and then the
dude yells again we are they'll go Penn
State they say it like five times and
then the end the guy who starts the
chant goes thank you and then everybody
screams you're welcome and I immediately
noticed that it annoyed the [__] out of
all these USC fans you know because they
kind of felt like it was a home game
because they were out there so next
thing you know I don't even think it
next thing you know coming out of my
mouth I'm going we're I'm I'm not from
Penn State I don't know [__] right but I
just said go we are
let's go and Penn State bad stain I'm
like thank you and they're like you're
welcome I'm like this is [__] awesome
I can do this the whole game and annoy
the [__] out of people around me so like
it took us 20 minutes 20 minutes to get
through the tunnel and I swear to God
was like perfect timing right as we got
through the tunnel
this chick is finishing singing the
national anthem as we just take in the
Rose Bowl on a sunny California day
everybody's wearing their Trojan colors
everybody's wearing that Penn State as
pom-poms people are going [__] nuts
and this lady's like and uh god brave
and what if she finished a [__]
stealth bomber slides right over the
goddamn top I'm shit-faced it's like a
[__] acid trip I almost passed out
right so now you know we got endzone
seats you know evidently I'm not a big
shot and we'll wait at the top of the
stadium which is a really rough thing to
negotiate when you're a redhead drinking
whiskey in the Sun right so we get all
the way up to like row whatever [__]
triple F and you know it's an old
stadium okay and you know back in the
day like you would tall if you were like
five foot six when the stadium was built
and now you know with [__] growth
hormones and all the preservatives in
the food we basically outgrown the
stadium's not to mention the Cheesecake
factories that have these [__] people
go to every other day so I'm trying to
walk a tightrope down I'm literally
acting this out of my bedroom by the way
this is how into these stories I get to
tell so I'm literally walking a [__]
tightrope trying to get down to my seat
and I just become that guy
I felt I didn't fall I sort of like like
lift it was almost like I was honest I
was the only guy on a ship that was in a
[__] perfect storm and all of a
sudden the whole thing just lifted to
the right side and I landed it on this
like 55 year old lady's back didn't like
land like I was do I was on one foot and
I put a nice forearm
while Samuelson in front of the net
[__] action right on her back and I
was so drunk it took me I swear to God
at least 28 seconds to get off her in
the entire time I am apologizing with my
[__] cigar whiskey breath is God's
eyes I and I just I couldn't get off her
because I the only way to get off of was
to put all my weight on my forearm and
use her as a banister to push me back up
because nobody's [__] helping me
because I'm obviously the drunk guy you
don't want to touch me so 28 seconds to
trying to figure out if I have the quad
strength to pull myself up without
pushing off the back of this old lady's
neck I finally just say [__] it and just
drive my the meat of my forearm right
between her shoulder blades and I get up
I apologize profusely and I don't know
what Joe was doing at this point he was
[__] probably just standing there
watching the game but basically we
finally get to our seats it was unreal
I know we got to our seats and I we turn
around we face the gate to watch the
game and next thing you know this lady
is just screaming at us she's like
screaming and she's yelling you can't
smoke in here
and I'm like what the [__] is she
talking about cuz I put my my cigar out
I'm gonna tell you do the [__] Cuban
is sweet too man died smoked that thing
all the way down like a goddamn roach
it's like burning my [__] fingers and
she's yelling stop smoking what the
[__] she talking about do I smell like
a cigar and I turn I look I look to my
right and Joe is standing there with the
[__] Cuban cigars still lit in his
mouth I don't know how the [__] he got
it past security
I think it's cuz we had our tickets
those ticket things I bought or robbed
our neck I don't know if he headed down
by his side but he's sitting at chomping
on it like [__] Archie Bunker so you
know in defense of me if she just turned
around and she had just said hey you
guys um you know that you I don't know
if you know but there's no smoking in
here
yeah I would have been you know I'm a
happy drunk I swear to god I'm angry
when I'm sober but I sweat it I'm a
happy
I just would have been like hey I bought
that we didn't know Oh ready for us CRA
good luck bah ha ha whatever I would
have kept it at that but she [__] was
yelling at us so I don't like being
yelled at and I like being full I like
[__] with people and I'm shit-faced
and Joe is of the same ilk and then
that's when it all started
she just based she's like hey she goes
there's no smoking in here and then
immediately I just go and I just go I
was like eh
says who she goes it's California I had
to smoke indoors were like we're outside
and she goes you're not allowed to smoke
and I go you're not my mother this isn't
our section this isn't your section turn
around
right I just kept being an [__] and
then finally she goes I'm gonna call
security
and I'm like column she goes I'm gonna
call him I go ahead and call him and
then in my head my brain is going bill
shut up shut up you're going to get
bored 90 seconds into the game you're
going to get kicked out and I just
couldn't stop myself
I just kept saying call him call him and
then then she made some sort of comment
I think about the size of Joe's nose and
then he said hey yeah because you need
to lose a hundred pounds to talk to me
[__] that's what he said and then this
guy to the left of us turns around and
he's like hey I got my kitty I got my
kid here what are you cursing then then
Joe goes well then don't bring them to a
[__] football so now I'm doing that
laughs you know that last where like
your mouth is wide open but there's no
air coming in or out I'm having the time
of my life and then the [__] guy goes
he goes I'm gonna call security and I'm
just let it once again I'm going call up
I'm gonna call God and call up Carla I
was just calling that Bluff because we
were so [__] jam-packed in I knew
they weren't going to walk down there
and go do that so that lady makes
another [__] comment
at which point Joe makes another comment
about a weight and then she just turns
down and is like mock and yells down to
her husband next thing you know this
[__] dude comes running over and he
starts screaming at it and he's
screaming at it this spray is coming out
of his mouth all over his wife so yeah I
was just going sir sir you're spitting
on your wife and once you know that hope
it was pathetic he was like 53 but like
and I'm 14 I'm thinking like that not
too old to fight this guy you know it
was just oh god I'm trying to piece this
together that so we all sit down right
so then we sit down
I think Joe had put out the cigar maybe
he was just holding it down I don't know
what was going on but now by this time
we already missed the kickoff the
Trojans get the ball and I think this is
basically the one good play Penn State
made all day they Trojans their first
play I think offense they hand it off
the ball and they try to do like some
sort of sweep the Penn State defense
strung it out and just stuck this guy
either for no gain or for like loss of
one yard and then Joe oh I forgot to
mention is a good six foot for just a
huge guy just starts screaming like an
inch from the back of the lady's head
who's a Trojan fan he just starts
screaming like I can't believe like her
hair wasn't moving he was yelling so
loud and she got out she turned around
she got that [__] obnoxious that's just
not I wish it was it was great it was
[__] great and then basically what
would have for the rest of the game [__]
would calm down and then we would we
would I don't know we would mumble
something about her and then she would
[__] yell down to her husband and
that he come over threatening to kick
our ass and we would just laugh at him
and then I don't know I just realized I
was so drunk I can't even remember the
rest of the I remember was at the very
end of the game somebody Joe or somebody
said something about the score and then
delay
in front of us goes yeah I'm surprised
you can count that high I go yeah why
don't you try counting calories right
something real mean like that and then
once again she's like mark and then at
this point half the crowded left because
of such a blowout this too comes over
and he starts [__] screaming at me
doesn't scream at Joe because Joe
six-foot-four yells at me because I'm
[__] barely 510 and I'm a [__]
redhead right even with the shaved head
I still look like [__] Howdy Doody so
he starts yelling at me and he keeps
telling me yeah I'm gonna fire you down
on the field
that's a kept saying tip tell me he's
gonna grab me and fire me down on the
[__] field and I was just yelling and
I would just be an [__]
glad dead do it gonna fire down the
field you said that you already said
that
you already said you already said it you
[__] [__] all right you got to do it
you would have and you didn't so you're
not so sit down and shut the [__] up
which is funny because by the end of the
game everyone in the stands
somehow liked us and hated those people
I mean half it was because they were
[__] the other half was they
couldn't hear the [__] that we will
mumble him at this dude's wife who I
know at this point he might have a
little bit of sympathy for but I mean
I'm telling you she was she was uh she
was an [__] and she's the one who
made it personal first she made the
comment about Joe's nose she oh she was
doing real hacky lines to she's told me
I was ugly she goes and I always can
lose weight you know which I believe I
saw during the second season of Def Jam
and you know and I thought what we would
come up with was a lot more clever and
if it was a battle of the bands in a
stand-up situation I think we won so uh
basically what ended up happening I know
this is a long ass [__] story I don't
have time for questions this week but
long story short we ended up walking out
I when I believe they died somehow the
lady in front of us to who was being a
jerk had a bunch of these dark streaks
on the back of her shirt towards the end
of it I don't know what it was
it almost looked like ashes from a cigar
but I know that that didn't happen
because there's no sir
poking in there but anyways we go to
leaves and we're basically so drunk I
don't know man it took us like [__]
nine hours it literally took us 50
minutes to find our car I think it was
Karma for being such [__] in in the
stadium and I don't I don't know who the
[__] set up the parking lots of things
out there but they basically the way
they do the sections on this golf course
is they have like balloons that they
just have numbers number one number two
number three but they're not lit up so
you can't really see him at night so you
walk out of the stadium drunk and you
look up and you see I saw the number two
where we were where we were parked and
but you know you got to follow the path
because you can't walk through the sand
traps and [__] like that so you look
down for half a second then you look up
and it's like a big [__] oak tree in
front of you and now you don't know
where you are it's like the end of the
shining without the shrubs
it's a [__] golf course right so and
you're far enough away from the stadium
where you can't get your bearings and
we're just wandering around and around
and around and it's getting to the point
like you know like hypothermia is
becoming an issue because it's a desert
it starts getting cold with shit-faced
and we just can find a car it was like
The Blair Witch we kept coming back to
the same goddamn ladies tees whatever
the [__] we were and then I lost all
confidence in my ability to find the
damn car so I start following Joe who is
convinced even though we both know we're
parked in section two we went from
section three to section four to section
five and he keeps telling me to go in
that direction because for some reason
he thinks numerically it's going to go
three four five - I don't know
took us an hour to find the [__] car
and at that point I started sobering up
and I started thinking about a behavior
and I was starting thinking like you
know I kind of kind of Philly an [__]
yeah you know should it say I should
have taken a higher ground even though
that girl was a [__] you know and he was
just like what are you talking about
what are you talking about you she was a
[__] we treated her like one
that's it so a lot about that guy he
just he just breaks it down to the
simplest [__] point hey buddy I got
my kid here but don't take your kid to a
[__] football game but you know I
know that's harsh especially if you have
kids but think about it think about it
why would you bring a kid to his
profession so to sporting a bit not only
that that the guy with the kid is being
hypocritical
because he was me before he had a kid
all right he was having the time of his
[__] life and what now because he has
a kid now all of a sudden I'm supposed
to I'm supposed to [__] act my age
you know it's like the [__] baby boom
generation they bang so much they
[__] in the mud at Woodstock
that by the time I come around there's
herpes and AIDS and all this [__] and
then these you know then they they come
around with their don't do drugs wear a
condom [__] after they had the time of
their [__] lives
I'm so glad all of them are getting that
whole generation is getting hip
replacements now with their [__]
because they all had that [__] Olivia
newton-john high impact aerobics tape
that they did trying to stay in shape
and so one good [__] Bank consider I
got a [__] with a goddamn trash bag
around my dick my entire career right
the very least I at least knew to
stretch before you lifted weights and I
also dangers of high impact aerobics
okay when I did my aerobics I definitely
was rocking the leg warmers but I did
not let my feet leave the ground okay
uh-huh
so anyways that's my Rose Bowl story um
the [__] law when I know that but I
think it had some nice moments but um
yeah but getting back to that what do
you guys think about that stuff you know
spoiling events are not for children
okay and I know they always try to talk
about the good old days of sports the
good old days of sports is [__] okay
when I was a kid first football game I
went to I was [__] terrified I was
terrified it was not a place for kids it
was a place for adults who hadn't
achieved what they thought they were
going to achieve in life to get their
[__] anger and frustration out people
with in loveless marriages you know
people you know people who could tell
they were going to get laid off the next
week or maybe they already got laid off
and they just wanted to get it out okay
and they you know they've now turned
going to a [__] football game into
like you're standing in line with a
bunch of people waiting to get their
kids you know photo taken with Santa
Claus you know and even if you go
further back than my childhood which was
70s early 80s if you go back to the
1950s they talk about that all the good
old days of sports what do you mean what
what when when they finally let a black
guy playing baseball and they threw a
[__] black hat on the field and all
that racist [__] that was going on can
you imagine the [__] that was getting
yelled in the stands when Billy Crystal
was going down they're gonna go watch
the mick boy oh boy I got myself a hot
dog and a sarsaparilla you know they
always tell those stories about how
great it was back then it wasn't it
wasn't great they were way more racist
way more ignorant way more sexist and
people went to the games and they saw
Johnny Unitas okay so now for some
reason now it's my turn to be an [__]
and be a drunk and have a good time and
all of a sudden I have to take
everything down a level you know not now
now it's it's chuck-e-cheese time it
isn't and I know you guys are saying
well that's because you don't have a kid
right now no [__] that
[__] that I wouldn't ring my kid to the
game or I brought to get a game I would
prepare them I prepare you know this is
what's gonna happen okay you might see a
fight you know hey dad might even get in
one
no I'm not I never took it to that level
you know I mean I think better
but it didn't help guilty I am for my my
behavior that they actually pulled up a
quote from George Orwell who granted
this is from Wikipedia which the other
day I looked up something that I knew
something about it was completely
interactive but this is according to
Wikipedia George Orwell said serious
sport has nothing to do with fair play
it's a bound up it's bound up with
hatred jealousy boastfulness disregard
of all rules and sadistic pleasures
pleasures and witnessing violence in
other words it's war - the shooting
exactly now why the [__] would you bring
a child to that and not only that when
was George Orwell alive a long [__]
time ago I don't know when he's alive
one of you right in 1984 he didn't write
in 83 I know that he won't like the 30s
did me
I'm just saying see that's how he
describes sports back then so guys like
you know these Billy Crystal guys always
do those little heartwarming stories
about you know their baseball cards and
going down to the baseball stadium and
acting like it was this [__] you know
this time that was lost
you know George Orwell right there
according to Wikipedia I think I proved
my point I'm a [__] but I did have a
good time let me tell you like this
right now if you ever get a chance you
like to smoke a Cuban cigar definitely
do it all right because I'm not even a
big smoker and I could tell how [__]
amazing that cigar was because I've
drank fine wines and I can't tell the
difference you know when it took me a
long time to be comfortable with myself
you know when you go through the whole
long process of spinning the big red
wine glass around I see read up on wine
to try to learn so I you know about it
so I wouldn't feel so [__] stupid
when they bring a nice bottle of wine
over and I'm like you know this tastes
like the [__] I used to drink in high
school you know I learned that you know
red wine the reason why it's in a bigger
glass is because I'm about the oxygen
and you want it to breathe more and how
to you know move it around the [__]
table and then you shove your [__]
nose all the way in it and yet put it in
you swish it all around your mouth I got
all the moves down and I'm like
swallowed on my guest this tastes like
every other [__] red wine I've
go ahead that's not true I can tell the
difference between like you know
Cabernet or Merlot or something like
that but like I can't tell like the
difference between a 1499 bottle and a
$60.00 bottle and you know I guess I'm
trying to say with this podcast I'm not
that cultured okay
all right well so why don't you guys
chime in with that okay like well do you
think maybe they should have a kid
section should they just have a
chuck-e-cheese section it's not my fault
you knocked her up and you can't go to a
game and have a good time now you know
you want to be getting drunk with me see
what I just did there that's how I made
myself right made this guy who can't
even defend himself actually be secretly
agreeing with me that's how I do it but
I mentioned I have a rat problem I have
a really nice apartment but the garage I
have is a glorified Shack like if they
ever decide to do the Hatfields and
McCoys TV series they could shoot it on
location in my garage okay is a rotting
out hunter [__] and even though the door
comes down the hole in the back of the
garage he granted you couldn't drive my
car out of it but a [__] rat could
crawl into it on a rainy night and then
crawl up into my engine and sleep this
[__]
I took my car down to get it serviced
and they took out the air conditioner
filter and it was rat [__] in there and
I got a pause for everybody gone and
yeah it's good so you know being a man
I'm like okay operation
kill the [__] rat is now in motion
and I sat there and I thought how can I
kill this [__] and basically
what I did was I went to a smaller
hardware because [__] Home Depot and
there eight people in aprons and I
bought a hundred and fourteen dollars
worth of those rat glue traps and I got
a couple of really big cardboard boxes
and then I took some duct tape
because when you don't know what the
[__] you doing duct tape is always a
solution and I duct-taped 28 of these
[__] I think over 30 I think I
lost count how many I did on all these
box onto big boxes side by [__] side
and I split them underneath my car okay
you want to get dry why don't you try to
get try get by that now I don't know
because rats are intelligent now I don't
know if what I have in my garage right
now is the Star Wars plan that Ronald
Reagan always dreamed of I don't know if
I have the red version of that or if I
have the imaginal line you know imagine
a line anybody anybody you want to read
up on that one that's one of the classic
military blunders of all time basically
Germany invaded you know France and
World War one it was trench warfare ton
ton of loss of life they came in they
got invaded they got overrun and all
that blah blah blah blah blah [__] so
they wanted to make sure they would
never happen again because they were
worried about Germany you know and why
wouldn't you been so they decided to
build like this is called imaginal line
and it was permanent trenches with these
these [__] basically built in and
literally an anti it wasn't
anti-aircraft that was the problem that
killed him it was [__] like
machine-gun nests like permanent all the
way around and they spent all this
[__] money on it and what's hilarious
is by the time they went to war with
Germany again they had perfected the
aircraft and they basically just flew
right up and over all the [__]
trenches you don't drop bombs on them
and [__] and they once again took over
[__] France and so I don't know I
don't know if the rat laughed at it
brought enough you know a couple friends
over to [__] inside of my car but I'm
going to kill that [__] and all you
animal lovers can go [__] yourselves
because I'm not losing a $23,000
automobile to a [__] rodent all right
I'm going to show him why I live inside
all right and I don't have to [__] on an
air conditioning filled filter okay
let's get the podcast questions shall we
people
I'll let you guys know how it goes if I
kill the rat or not all right Podcast
question number one bill since you're a
Patriots fan I got to ask you what's
your honest opinion on the Tuck rule
game I'm a Raider fan and I think that
was hands-down the biggest [__] call
in the history of sports and still of
this day I carry it with me the fact
that the eight and eight charges made
the playoffs over the eleven and five
Patriots made me happy inside and while
I respect Tom Brady is one of the great
all-time cubies if he snapped his leg in
three places I'd be a happy man okay for
those of you aren't big sports fans the
Tuck rule was basically is basically a
rule with a quarterback if he goes I
basically goes into the passing motion
doesn't throw the ball and if he brings
it back to his chest if somebody whacks
the ball out then it's considered an
incomplete pass or something I really
should have looked up the tough rule and
and you know basically the Raiders
slapped the ball out of Brady's hand
they fell on it they had thought they
won the game because it was a fumble and
then the they brought out this the top
rule which nobody had ever heard of
including probably Tom Brady when he
wants to know what is my feeling on that
I don't feel it was a big relax let me
finish I don't feel it was the biggest
[__] call in the history of sports I
think it's the biggest [__] rule in
the history of sports that's the thing
they made the right call the rule needed
to be changed I think it's a [__]
rule I think that that should have been
a fumble it is a fumble he didn't tuck
it he was going to throw it and he
didn't and then he pulled it in he got
slapped it is a fumble but that's what
it should be but because of the Tuck
rule it was actually the right call but
it's a [__] rule and I'm big enough
to admit that but the reality is you
know why that happened to you and why
you carry that with you oh poor baby
you've had to carry that since what 2001
poor baby you know what I had to carry
for almost 20 years was that roughing
the passer
call you're probably too young to
remember this but we basically beat the
[__] Raiders in 1976 we had you guys
beaten
sugarbear Hamilton is coming in against
Ken Stabler he jumps in the air once
again I'm acting this out he jumps in
the air as Stabler is going to release
the ball he's in the [__] air the
ball is released he slams into Ken
Stabler and they call roughing the
passer like he was supposed to change
midair now I don't know if you guys know
this [__]
but back then roughing the passer was
not a yardage penalty they basically put
the ball where they were trying to
complete it and it was the end of the
game and they threw a [__] 50-yard
Hail Mary they called roughing the
passer so they gave him the ball now
it's not on the 50 they put it on like
the [__] three yard line and the
Raiders went in to go score that my
friend was the biggest [__] call of
all time because that was a complete
wrong interpretation of the rule you
understand the difference the top rule
is a [__] rule that was interpreted
correctly so the guy made the correct
call he did make the correct call but I
feel for you because that was a [__]
that was a bit of [__] rule and the
Raiders should have won that game but
that was payback because the Patriots
should have beat you in 1976 but because
a lot of you Raider fans are a lot
younger you don't remember it or maybe
you don't want to remember but I carried
that from 1976 to 2001 alright so that
was 15 years all right youngster you're
only seven years into your [__] so I
have no sympathy for you okay sorry I
get eaten when it comes to sports and he
said something what's the next one
what's your what's your opinion on the
field goal guy you know if you put a
bunch of guys I don't want to [__]
read this one I went too long and that
when I get get Achatz and some other
people I don't mind field goal kickers
by the way sorry I stood on my old
laptop I'm trying to not hit this button
too much all right bill um I want your
comedic opinion on something I was
talking to a co-worker of mine about a
girl that I had been seeing I love this
question this is a great story
everybody just settle in settling in
turn this turn this down turn this down
because I think this has does this have
the word continent I'm not sure okay
here we go all right bill I want your
comedic opinion on something I was
talking to a co-worker of mine about a
girl that I'd been seeing that I've been
kind of seeing I was telling him that
one thing I really like about her is how
he wrote this on how her how good her
hair smells
well--there's [__] of a girl that works
with me overheard us and decided to
chime in by saying [__] like she wants
she wants to meet the girl who would go
out with a guy like me and how she would
actually be nervous to be alone with me
all right I know my reading out loud
skills sucks so let me just sort of
paraphrase what happens this guy's at
work he's kind of seeing this girl and
he says to friend of his yeah you know
seeing this girl you know I really love
you and her hair smells really great
that's all I have this instant
conversation and then this other girl
who's not even in the conversation is a
hey I got it but I'd love to meet the
girl go out with you
you know I'd be nervous to be alone with
you right completely uncalled-for and he
goes etc so now we recently found out
that that girl who chimed in just had an
abortion like a week and a half ago
Jesus but I brushed her off I brushed
her off but the [__] didn't stop she
continued on by asking another female
worker if she'd be nervous to be alone
with me which my response was why don't
you at why don't we ask someone what
it's like to be alone with you oh wait a
minute that's right you killed it Wow
Wow dude you said that at work Wow
okay okay and he basically says which
shocked half of the people at work and
made the other half crack up laughing
she called me an insensitive [__]
yeah okay but I could care less to me
she was asking for it it's not like she
was just sitting there minding her own
business and I walked up and said what's
new fetus killer what do you think bill
was I out of line or was it a kick-ass
comeback okay let me wrap my [__]
head around this um all right first of
all it was an unbelievable comeback
it was a game set and match comeback you
know it was literally you know I don't
know
she didn't even bring a knife to a
gunfight she was sitting there with a
water pistol and you took out a machete
and you [__] chopped her head off and
I don't know held it up for everyone to
see and then you swung up her [__]
head around by the ponytail and threw it
across the offices basically what you
did um well what do you think was I out
of line yeah I'm gonna have to say yes
because I totally understand why you
went there
like why you wanted to hurt her back
because what she was saying to you was
[__] up but she was [__] up on like
level two and then you went right to the
penthouse level you know I mean I might
even say level two she was a good she
was a good a third of the way up the
building okay I don't know why I'm using
a building as an analogy but I'm too
deep now I have to go with this but you
went right to the penthouse suite and
you kicked her ass right off of it and
you didn't even do it on the side you
know where they have that that canopy
thing with a bellman stance we're in a
Three Stooges movie you'd somehow live
you kicked her out the back side of the
building right down into the [__]
alley where there's a rat waiting to
crawl up into my [__] car
yeah what I would what I don't know how
old you are but you yeah you kind of
went well you didn't have to go where
you would you have to do is you get
older both with men and women as
psychologically you have to realize
where they're coming from and you have
to understand especially knowing that
she had just had an abortion dude which
is [__] is is that's brutal for a guy
to go through you know if you have any
sort of a conscious forget about a woman
who's actually caring you know I'm
saying and so the reason why she's
saying she obviously is having
difficulty with her own relationships
and is so [__] insecure that to hear
someone around her actually maybe making
some sort of connection and be happy in
that area of her life is [__] with
her so much that it wasn't enough just
to say the mean [__] to you she starts
walking around the office like trying to
get people to like reinforce her
statement and to sort of [__] block you
and I understand why why you did that
you know you know you gotta understand
why you went to that level okay you went
literally to that level that had nothing
to do with her that adds some [__] to do
the baggage you were bringing I don't
know what house you selling you came
from a household like my household where
uh you know somebody makes fun of your
shirt you like at least my [__] uncle
isn't dead you know you know you just
admit you mmediately go way beyond what
was just said to you so uh was it out of
line definitely out of line dude you
shouldn't say [__] like that at work
I don't want you to lose your job but
you know I'm not glad he was [__]
hilarious
and not to mention hooter for after my
Rose Bowl story who the [__] am I to say
anybody was out of line
I'm paying you know where I'm at this is
like your story oh I'm trying to break
it down how you ended up there is where
I'm at as a human being right now I'm
still doing the what's new fetus killer
lines but I'm trying not to do that
you know it's funny on a comedy stage
but it's it's not funny at the Rose Bowl
all right but dude I got to give you you
know I got to give you a [__] over
the phone high five on that one that was
just wow why don't we ask someone who's
been with palom with you oh wait a
minute that's right you killed it
there's no white people bursted out
laughing that's one of those things if
you found it funny you made that you
know you raise your eyebrows up like
holy [__] you got to walk away you know
to me somehow there has to be a corner
within ten yards for you to walk around
so you can let that laugh go goddamnit
death that was brutal but that was funny
come on women you got a laugh but you
got to know that's funny I know I know
it's brutal but come on that was funny
okay where we go where we go all right a
lot of sports questions all of a sudden
people really like the sports okay
another question bill what happened to
our beloved team this is a Boston person
do the Patriots try and keep Matt Cassel
knowing Tom Brady is rehabbing his rehab
is slightly behind do the Jets offer
back the second round they gain from
Spygate back for the Pats man you're
going real detail I have no idea what's
happened to our beloved team the
Patriots had an unbelievable season and
what I love about it is everyone was
questioning bills Bill Parcells on Bill
Parcells Bill Belichick because of the
Spygate thing and you know look at this
year after winning with the sixth round
pick three Super Bowls seventh round
draft pick he goes 11 and five and
almost wins the division
I think he's proven himself as a [__]
coach and people always really good book
inspired gate but they got nothing they
don't have an argument and the reason
why I said Bill Parcells is because I
really think that that guy is overrated
you know I think he's really good at
making a team good but he can't get them
over the top
and he throws temper tantrums when he
doesn't get his way and he totally he's
like the Larry Brown of football you
know he's only won two Super Bowls 86
and 90 and who was his [__] defensive
bill belichick all right he got to the
Super Bowl again with the Patriots who
was his defensive coordinator Bill
Belichick right you see Bill Belichick
has gone on won three Super Bowls
Parcells has won nothing 2-1 nothing he
changes the colors of team he definitely
gets a winning tradition going on there
but he doesn't win so I'd rather have
Belichick in order to realize he's a
great coach I'm just still pissed that
he'd CT announced that he was leaving
our team a week before we were going to
play Super Bowl for his own selfish
reasons I really annoyed me all right
question number was around four okay for
those you not into sports here we go
here's a non sports stories bill when
you do an appearance on a big show like
Letterman or Conan what's the protocol
for meeting the other guests
does the show hook that up automatically
or the guests isolated from each other
and the dressing room and green rooms
the reason I ask is NBC just recently
had a replay of your Conan episode that
you appeared on with Keira Knightley was
the headliner I assume one of the perks
and doing the show is getting to check
out a famous chicken person right no you
don't you are on an entirely different
floor than the actual famous people
you're just the comedian so I don't know
what it's like to do panel I've never
done panel that's kind of one of my
goals here for 2009 maybe I can do pone
panel on one of the later later shows
like Carson Daly I just have to have
something to hype maybe I can do that
then I'd love to do that but I've only
been a comedian so basically you know
you're on count on your own floor on
Letterman you're on you have like your
own floor to yourself which is cool and
kind of creepy and then on Conan you're
when I did Conan you know what I
definitely definitely more I don't know
why they put the famous people because
I'm not near them but I did walk out and
after Chuck Norris did his sketch I made
sure when he walked by me I shook his
hand you know thinking like that hand
shook Bruce Lee's hand you know what I
mean at least blocked his [__] kick
or some [__] in whatever movie that was
but no no you don't get to meet those
people some some people are cool you
know I remember the first time we did
Conan Mary Tyler Moore walked by I
looked into my room smiled and said
hello you know I think a lot of times
people are sitting back there thinking
what stories am I going to tell you get
your head together and you already have
your crew of people you know people who
book you and that type of stuff and
because personally before I go out and
do my set like literally you know once
the show starts after the first segment
I kind of send you know all my people
out of the room so I can kind of just
basically remember what my opening joke
is so there you go all right question
numbers or whatever we're on I have
these numbered wrong for some reasons is
three even islands like five I have a
question about your storytelling ability
when you told the story about getting
the hot dog from Pink's it was not only
hilarious but I felt like I was there I
suck at being able to replay the funny
[__] that happens to me my families and
friends does your story ability come
naturally or is it something that you've
worked on how do you put together a good
story
I'm actually not the greatest
storyteller I digress a lot and I'm
trying to get to get to the meat of it a
lot better but yeah it just kind of
comes from telling a lot of stories but
uh but don't beat yourself up man you
know there's a lot of people who can't
tell a story but it's more like they are
the story you know what I mean like I
don't know I got a good friend of mine
who did he does the funniest [__] ever
and he has you on the grind he does [__]
offstage I wouldn't do on stage and he
has you on the ground laughing but he
tells the story it doesn't sound like
anything funny happened but like in the
moment he's like the funniest guy ever
like it's weird like I know how I told
that Rosebowl story I was just trying
not to get the other dude in trouble but
the other dude kind of was the story Joe
was [__] hilarious
I don't know and then afterwards I'm
telling the story I'm the story guy I
tell the [__] story but I'm not the
[__] story all right I'm just a sad
little man retelling [__] that I didn't
do okay question number
all right hey what's the word oh you
know what I got this one totally wrong
like someone asked me a couple weeks
back about what I think about the
Chicago Blackhawks I was only mildly
paying attention to them I didn't
realize how good they were this year and
I started watching them I think that
they're going to go maybe a couple
rounds into the playoffs this year and
I'll see you ask me why the [__] see the
Bruins get rid of Thornton and I you
know we're saying why you know they kind
of blamed our shortcomings on him but I
forgot that we got we got phil kessel in
that trade so we did get something sort
of a trying to correct something there
all right let me try to get to the rest
of these all right here's the New Year's
resolutions people I know this is
getting along
New Year's resolutions I never
understand why I'd my ship is we can go
get the Improv in Tampa go to improv the
number to calm for all the information
we can click right on my home page
please come out to see me at The Improv
in Tampa I got a whole new hours [__]
and yeah come on man
can't be just listen to me for free and
my podcast I know it's a tough economy
but for the Christ's sake come on [__]
support me all right new year's
resolutions all right bill a lot of
people are against them here's a guy
have no I never had stood the logic of
New Year's resolutions there's 64 other
days a year when one can decide to do
something better for themselves perhaps
it's another marketing scheme for
capitalists bloodsuckers I'm hoping that
we we will make another hoping that will
make another irrational decisions it's
not really a more of a statement I kind
of agree with that I absolutely hate New
Year's resolutions people trick
themselves into believing that the best
time to make changes and start things is
at the begin of the year I don't make
new year's resolutions because they are
unnecessary I start every new year off
with what I refer to as my three golden
rules one laughs my ass off every chance
I get to after I have done what I can I
walk away from those things that I
cannot fix or resolve and three I
surround myself with people places and
things I love most and support Who I am
as a person Jesus Christ as somebody
who's healthy huh
um alright or where we go in here where
we go let's wrap this [__] thing up
with the quick overrated underrated and
I'm actually going to pitch it because
you guys have been doing such a great
job here I'm going to say overrated is
the movie 300 that's it's just that it's
laugh-out-loud awful the second time you
see the first time you see it visually
it's really interesting but it's just
the stupidest [__] thing ever it's
the complete meathead what it means to
be a man and you know the the kid you
know is crying for his mother and they
[__] stick him in a loincloth out in
the wilderness it's snowing out he's
walking around in his bare feet and he
kills some sort of hybrid wolf slash
alien with a stick and I'm supposed to
believe that and and you know and then
they had the Fight Club moment where he
murders another [__] half-naked
six-year-old with this kid there's
smaller dogs and they kick him down that
[__] manhole and that one guy just of
the beautiful backflip as he goes it's
[__] gay all right they take on an
army of 20,000 you know what I mean you
know what that movie is that's the
fantasy every man has after he [__]
out and a bunch of women some [__] out
in like a bar fight or something like
that and then when you're driving home
and you start dreaming of the man you
wish you weren't how you looked in
[__] you know mood lighting [__] that
movie movie sucks it really sucks okay I
think half those ABS were painted on
once I saw that Janet Jackson does that
you know that you can actually do some
shadowing there on the stomach okay uh
if somebody is say sum over a dime very
overrated losing your virginity but god
but god sex rules when you figure it out
later in life also my guitar playing to
my friends is underrated bill burr the
funniest man alive and chicken wings are
also under underrated the greatest food
ever chicken wings are great when you're
younger but once your stomach is so full
of grease when you're in your Middle
Ages you can't eat them anymore so enjoy
underrated jerky it's a good source of
protein
tene low in fat and it's tasty great
snack yeah but you got to go to a truck
stop to get it and there's always the
danger of being raped there man or woman
underrated being and familiar enough
company to talk some serious [__] and do
some serious ball busting there's
nothing worse than going out with some
people you kind of know but you don't
know enough to know their limits so you
can't mix it up verbally with my friends
at bars watching a game it's great
knowing I don't need to censor myself
but with my girlfriend in general
acquaintances on couples nights it feels
like I'm eating with my grandparents
it's all small talk no substance and I'm
constantly censoring myself it's a
psychological prison exactly I'd have to
agree with you on that one
totally would have to agree with you
that last couple of things I think
that's basically it that's the podcast
for this week I hope you enjoyed my long
ass [__] stories happy New Year to
everybody I hope you guys have a great
new year and I hope you can stick with
your new year's resolutions personally
I've been I'm doing what I always do
getting myself in shape the first half
of the year before I completely get back
out of shape and nosedive with some
Christmas cookies at the end of the year
that's what I do but you know bikini
season is coming up um yeah you know I
did actually bought that p90x thing that
they have late at night and I got to
admit dude it's the [__] [__] once
you get past the guy hosting it you know
I don't know if I already talked about
this he's kind of if you're doing a
sketch about a personal trainer and you
imitated this guy they think that what
you were doing wasn't realistic he goes
oh yeah p90x you know tuck sorry there's
a nice shoes they're almost as cool as
mine okay let's drop down and do some
crunches but after a while you get to
see that he's just you know he's just a
big insecure guy you know I think I
talked about this right halfway through
we admit that his dad threw a couple of
no-hitters you know and you're like
there's the pain right and you never
lived up to him athletically did you so
now you joined a gym and the very least
you're trying to be in better shape than
your old man
because you just want to hug did that
make any sense it probably did
that's the podcast thank you for
listening and
and that's it I don't know how to end it
I never know how to [__] in it go see
me at Tampa go see me in Tampa at the
[__] The Improv in Tampa because I'll
be in Tampa in Florida at Tampa okay and
also be at the improv in Houston and I'm
also coming back Boston my triumphant
return to Boston Massachusetts and all
my dates are up my website bill burr
calm and all the information all the
links all that [__] and for those of you
who are wondering what happened to my
date at the Trump Taj Mahal the Atlantic
City whatever the [__] I was going to be
I'm gonna get a date up there we had to
reschedule it all right that is it
god bless all yes and [__] don't go
to the automated lines as grocery stores
all right that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
you